ich bin dafür dass dort wo die inzidenz
des zu lassen
schulen und kitas auch sein sollten
und dort wo wir noch hohe instanzen
haben sie zu sein müssen so machen wir
das schon die ganze zeit ganz praktisch
in mecklenburg vorpommern
wir haben wo wir geringe instanzen haben
die kitas und schulen grundschulen offen
gelassen und die präsenzpflicht
ausgesetzt und wo wir hohe haben zb im
hotspot vorpommern greifswald gibt es
nur notbetrieb und ich rate dazu dass
wir das auch in ganz deutschland machen
denn gerade bei kita und schule kann man
ja regional vorgehen da muss ich ja
nicht warten bis auch der letzte
landkreis in deutschland wieder in den
zahlen runter gekommen ist und das haben
wir auch als pflicht gegenüber den
kindern warum sollen denn kinder in der
stadt rostow mit einer inzidenz richtung
20 nicht in die kita und schule gehen
entschuldigen sie bitte wenn ich da
einmal ein haken darf es heißt immer
kitas sind zu von meiner freunde aus nrw
weiß ich sie muss eigentlich jedes kind
nehmen sie hat eine private kita auch
bei ihnen im land soll jedes zweite kind
in die kita gehen
wie sieht es in der realität aus
bezüglich kitas sind zu wir haben die
regel dass wir in hotspots wie zum
beispiel den vor landkreis
vorpommern-greifswald kita notbetreuung
haben also dort können nur eltern die
eben eine bescheinigung vom arbeitgeber
haben dass sie dringend arbeiten müssen
die kinder bringen
wir haben aber auch regionen wo wir die
kitas offen gelassen haben und auf
freiwilligkeit gesetzt haben das hat
sehr gut geklappt lassen sie mich ein
beispiel nennen
der landkreis nordwestmecklenburg hatte
eine inzidenz von 120 hier haben wir
gesagt eltern bitte dass die kinder
zuhause und wir arbeiten muss oder aus
sozialen gründen kann die kinder
schicken
heute sind wir in dem landkreis bei fast
40 instanz also runter gekommen
wir haben es genauso in der grundschule
gemacht und es hat sich gezeigt weder
die kitas noch die schulen waren ein
infektions treiber im gegenteil wir sind
hier in diesem landkreis wieder
runtergekommen wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube
ob zum nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren